bienvenidos a es un día más a nuestra
crónica deportiva del mediodía para ello
contamos con nuestra periodista
especializada en deportes eeuu males a
aumar vamos a comenzar con el tour de
francia que en esta última etapa
pirenaica parece que ya se ha decidido
si de nuevo hubo pulso entre el líder y
el campeón vigente pero esta vez el
dueño del maillot amarillo jonas bean
llegar amplió su ventaja sobre tarde y
podrá ser el relato de la etapa 18
corrida hoy entre lourdes y atacan no
tiene la periodista de france 24
erika olavarría erika como se desarrolló
la jornada
hola buenas tardes bueno fue una carrera
muy emocionante y difícil difícil se
sabía porque era la última etapa de
montaña con tres puertos de montaña dos
de categoría especial pero sin duda
atractiva por ese duelo entre el actual
poseedor de la camiseta amarilla el
danés lindegaard y por el actual
campeona del tour de francia el lb no
ponga char justamente fue al descender
uno de esos puertos de montaña el desván
de ella que bien llegar casi casi se cae
pero en realidad fue algunos metros
después el esloveno ponga char el que
terminó cayendo y allí se produjo uno de
los momentos que esas más emocionantes
de este tour de francia y una de las
imágenes que va a quedar para la
historia cuando el danés lo espera le da
la mano y juntos continúan en la carrera
para mucho ese gesto quiere decir
también que el danés decía que estaba
seguro de ganar esta etapa y casi casi
también de ganar este tour de francia'
de hecho para gastar queda a 3 minutos
26 segundos del jr algo que parece muy
difícil de remontar en las tres etapas
que quedan incluida la contrarreloj el
sábado hay que decir también que el
danés estuvo mejor acompañado primero
por el belga van herck que estuvo casi
casi toda la carrera no es cierto al
frente de los corredores y también por
el americano cus que lo acompañó mucho
rato en ese duelo con pocas charlas del
lado latinoamericano nos quedamos con un
poco de tristeza creímos en algunos
momentos en una victoria del colombiano
dani martínez que estuvo mucho rato
también en ese grupo que iba a la cabeza
de los corredores y también tristes por
nairo quintana que llegó 15 que queda
quinto en la clasificación general y
parece difícil verlo en el podio de los
campos elíseos bueno dedica muchas
gracias por resumir nos esta etapa que
realmente ha sido muy emocionante había
muchas cosas que contar y como bien ha
dicho
los corredores binger y poca chance nos
han dejado probablemente una de las
imágenes del tour de francia le
agradecemos otra vez y pasamos ahora a
colombia a la copa américa femenina si
venezuela y argentino van a chocar esta
noche por un último cupo en juego en el
grupo b donde las dos fueron goleadas
por brasil y ganaron el resto de sus
partidos vamos con estefanía montero
envía especial de france 24 en armenia a
ella le preguntamos que se puede augurar
de este partido
en armenia seguramente no solamente
veremos estos hermosos paisajes sino que
en la noche de hoy vamos a ver un gran
espectáculo de fútbol dos selecciones
que además solamente se han enfrentado
una sola vez en copa américa femenina
que fue en el pasado en el pasado
certamen del 2018 en el que argentina
ganó 2 goles por 0 se vuelven a
enfrentar esta noche al todo o al nada
esa es la premisa de cada una de las
elecciones que vamos a encontrar un
venezuela con un crecimiento
futbolístico en los últimos cuatro años
importante trascendental además que
viene de ganar sus partidos amistosos
previos a la copa américa de ganarle a
chile ya eliminada también de estos
cupos directos una argentina que viene
en un alza también en un desarrollo
deportivo importante figuras por la
parte de las venezolanas de ina
castellanos oriana altuve la misma
central maría peraza en el lado de las
argentinas que vamos a ver una estefanía
banini muy importante del mediocampo una
yamila rodríguez que además en el
entrenamiento en el que presenciamos el
día de ayer nos dijo que quería hacer
goleadora del torneo y está enfocada en
eso quieren estar en esa pelea de las
semifinales quieren ir a juegos
olímpicos quieren ir al mundial de forma
directa
hablamos con aldana comet y jugadoras de
la selección argentina y esto nos dijo
previo al importante y decisivo partido
frente a venezuela crecimos mucho porque
era liga se profesionaliza en argentina
muchas de nosotras tuvimos la
posibilidad de ir a jugar fuera eso hace
que el nivel crezca que la competencia
entre nosotros también crezca mucho y
aprovechando todo esto estamos hoy acá
buscando estar como te dije antes
nuevamente en un mundial no tenemos otra
cosa que salir a ganar sería buscar el
partido por más de lo que vos dijiste
que matemáticamente
tengamos más cosas a favor nosotros
queremos ganar queremos ser
protagonistas queremos hacer nuestros
juegos
bueno más agradecer a nuestra enviada
especial a colombia también como ya lo
hemos hecho antes a nuestra enviada
especial al tour de france y por
supuesto aquí por este repaso deportivo
seguro que estarás muy atenta al partido
de venezuela
ya nuestros telespectadores les
invitamos a que sigan conectados a
france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]